John and I are asking the nerdfighters
to help us create the happy dance
project Hank and I were sitting around
the other day and we said to each other
you know would be more awesome than if
we made a happy dance compilation video
if all of the nerdfighters sent us their
happy dances dancing in front of their
awesome places in their towns and
neighborhoods and then we made a happy
dance compilation video using all
nerdfighter happy dances
you can't contain your all sounds and
feelings rising through your body
feeling joyful thankful crazy when
you're feeling happy
down the home Ungh Oh Nanak rabbanut
bottles rip you're all alone anytime of
day when appealing Graham Jill you're
really
you
baby happy dances smiie these videos are
so crazy and sexy and cool they could
kill the giant don't try to contain it
set yourself go you so regret it if you
move it like I got shake it like y'all
everyone has on
you do when you're incredibly happy
you might friend on dirt get to the pier
yes it builds up without self of de
canoas are
Bukit Barisan decocking awesome producer
immersive tosya is a garbage Muslims big
bite - destroy it Bravo actor loss of a
most delicate area police robbery the
best doctor by the way
I feel like this value
yes I'll say that
I love my dad
yes it builds up without support a
historical person get cocky Moses am a
producer Amazonia is a garbage monster
spit by destroy a flu actor loss of a
most delicate area police robbery best
outcome but oh my
I feel like this value
I'll say it cuz I got it
I bought four dead
yes if a vodka this time is it Bob tip
that's a significant I recorded a la da
da da coach it fagner even Okanagan fact
it was an awesome photo collage it's a
local psychic cop again
but
if I got it dog
for me that night
you
on the lake
but I need
I just am
to pay the future whatever year it
seemed to work better place because I'm
rubbish we don't need to worry about the
nut butters Baker's from community we
can pick up today we celebrate
make it
well
Oh
splendid nails you bought us in my bath
you brought us picking a TVA you're
honest Pongo went ahead you got us all
some you wanna gather
thank you
yeah
you